I read when it comes to your own  personal tastes we're talking peanut  butter on pumpernickel and canned tuna  yeah so I'm kind of sick of food I've  been it's like a food for a few years  now but that would seem to be a problem  no I mean I mean I love when people do  food well but I have to eat so much food  and test so much food in the end you  just yearn for the most simple things so  peanut butter on pumpernickel  a tuna can of tuna fish right out of the  can pure it's not all Dolly got it  dialed up by a chef there's not tons of  stuff I just went simple when I when I'm  home I want to eat like a five-year-old  I like eating like a Bible word cat yes